so we're gonna have a little deep dive
into machine learning today I thought
would take the opportunity to build some
models and stuff like that and we're
gonna have a look at like useful
applications in machine learning so
we're gonna start off with some use
cases so I couldn't resist I know that
you had an astronaut here today and I
thought I had to take a photo that you
should all know from the calper belt so
the little blue dot there that's us in
1990 this was voyager turning back at
six billion yeah six billion kilometers
from Earth and actually looking and
saying bye you know and that's all that
was left of us this little blue dot so
I'm going to zoom in a bit because my
use case is actually down here on earth
this is my favorite view of the earth
every time I get in a plane and I fly
across the Atlantic I start playing
around for that screen once I've watched
all twenty films I didn't see and then I
started looking at where the planes
flying and then I'm twiddling the globe
around and I always like to get this
backward face of the globe where you
can't see any land on it I think it's a
really nice way of looking at the planet
and it gives you a kind of perspective
you know it really kind of messes with
your head a little bit you know you have
to think is it really so this year's
case I'm going to tell us about actually
whenever we tell this use case at Google
conference for example we always
mentioned this island and I didn't know
where it was so I thought I'd take the
effort and find out where it was and it
happened to be slap the hanging in the
middle of that view that I like to look
at so much and I don't know if you can
see this here properly so the I and the
island is called Kiribati and this
island has villages on it to this
nothing to when she learning at this
which is really interesting so this
island has villages on it of London
Paris Poland okay and banana so like if
you're ever looking to entertain you
kids so what is the UK so the use case
is global fishing maybe some of you've
heard about it it's a really cool use
case and normally we show this picture
so we show this picture of all these
boats moving around and Africa and
Madagascar so I thought Kiribati was
there but it's not it's on the other
side so that's that was my little
adventure into coming up to this use
case
so what's going on here basically
whenever a fishing boat passes through a
certain zone they want to know if
they're actually allowed to be fishing
there and whenever they catch someone
that's illegally fishing they say oh we
were just passing through yeah that's a
bit of a problem okay if their nets were
down in the water but you know you've
got some time to get the nets out they
say oh we're passing through so the
machine learning application that they
looked at was actually to take this data
and we're talking about 40 billion rows
of events and we got like 200 thousand
ships broadcasting a is all the time
that's the little positioning stuff of
boats and what they did was actually
work out how these boats are traversing
the water and what patterns correspond
to fishing patterns and they applied
this and so they could actually now
actually start finding well fishing
companies that were illegally fishing
and one of the first ever successful
prosecutions was for in the in the
waters of Kiribati and they find that
the actual issues was 2.2 million which
was one percent of the country's global
GDP this is something you can do with
machine learning I'm guessing most
people here are interested in fishing
waters and stuff like that so this is
like really take note and you can start
playing this as off I'm gonna take a few
use cases today from retail and there is
something to retailers because I think
it's quite broad you know and everyone
has some association with retail either
we're working with retail or we're we're
involved in buying for ourselves so we
got a good understanding so Okada is a
British supermarket they're online
they're online only it's got a ton of
active customers well five tons of them
to be precise and basically what they
want to do they want to process all the
messages they're coming at them so they
call this messages coming in on email or
social media and things like that
and if one of their customers is unhappy
about something maybe the delivery
didn't turn up on time although the food
was damaged or whatever they want to
capture that message and act so there
you know customer satisfaction is like
really important to them so they have to
process all these messages this message
here it's like you know someone I'm
happy you know my children up the
website is it's so easy and blower
that's great we're right back to that
but maybe later you know the thing that
we need to deal with now and maybe
another message is coming at us which is
you know
where's my food so it's a way that they
can actually take text unstructured text
and basically process that apply NLP so
natural language processing we offer an
API for this and they can actually then
find out what the sentiment of the Texas
extract the entities and they can then
go and use this to actually help provide
a better customer satisfaction this and
I'm not going to read them all out
because it's gonna take a long time but
these are some of the areas within
retail where you might want to look at
machine learning and it's actually quite
a lot I mean so it ranges from
everything from supply chain to pricing
to you know customer insights so we've
got this whole range so it's not just in
one area it might be that you're looking
for anomalies it might be you're trying
to forecast a trend or you're trying to
predict you're trying to make a
recommendations so they're all these
kind of applications that you can use
machine learning for to actually improve
your business whether that's inside to
actually become more economic or outside
to improve your relationships with your
customers or generate more revenue or
those important things this is just a
number it's done by research company but
I want this number it's just basically
the thing this is not the only important
number out there but nine and ten people
in their survey said if the company was
in they're able to predict my intent
better and suggest more intuitive
products I would use them above everyone
else now I know there are tons of you
know research firms come up with tons of
statistics like this but I just want to
think about it for a moment I just want
to ask you like to think about okay if
this is happening if customers are
starting to expect something more from
us can we afford not to do this I I
would say that the answer is no maybe I
mean I'm sure there's a lot of
discussion to be had around that but if
I look at my own life my personal life I
see more and more how I interact with
machine learning and AI or the result
the product of that whether it's for
example when I connect us Wi-Fi and I'm
actually want to find some new music or
when it's as Bill showed us earlier I'm
trying to work on a document like now
and I can just go and fly
docu is becoming more and more something
I use and it's becoming more and more
intuitive and I think our customers they
really appreciate like advice which is
actually seems this is not something
this is obstructive this is something
that's just actually improving my might
and my engagement with you so I think
that companies are already acting in
this space so companies are actively
thinking about this space if they have a
great chance of actually going forward
and and and and being more successful
with their customers but what this means
is that there's a lot of work that needs
to be done behind the scenes to actually
get that information out so we can start
doing these things recommendation angels
don't just pop up out the ground you
know you have to think about what data
am I gonna use for it how am I gonna
collect that data how am I going to
process it which model should I choose
and when you've done all of those things
you think I great I have this fantastic
model now it's able to predict stuff for
me and my customers really like it that
was today tomorrow there's more insight
there's more data things are changing
you need to go and retrain that model
and see if your new model is actually
more predictive and more useful than
what you have before if you're not doing
that you know you're there your static
these things don't just learn by
themselves you need to go and actually
feed the new data and retrain them so
this is a very simple naive look a
neural network neural networks are
immensely popular at the moment for all
sorts of things including things like
recommendations there are more classical
regression models and mystic for real
question other than I there are more
classical things that you could use to
do a recommendation a collaborative feel
thing for example but people are
starting to use they're looking at the
capacity of neural network because newer
networks have something that's really
quite unique to them I would say and
that's the ability to generalize very
well if you can't generalize what what
does that mean it means for example if I
was creating a model which was taking
advantage of a whole load of features
and then trying to get a good regression
and let's say I'm overfitting because
I'm just plugging all that stuff in
there and I think ok this is working
well but then I go and apply that to a
new set of people whether in the same
domain but they say on the edge of it
and things are changing my model if it's
too specific in
not really recognize their behavior
what's going on deep neural networks
help with that they're very good at
generalizing so for recommendations
there's actually ways that you can take
like the good parts of regression with a
more let's say a more classical setup
and then go for a deeper neural network
in the same model to actually get a
model which is but has both aspects of
memorization so learning the things are
important there is seen before but at
the same time flexible enough to
actually be useful and not just come
with the same answer because it's this
so what's changed in the last few years
why is this all happening now well
machine learning has been around for a
long time and a lot of the models that
you see especially using competitions up
into a few years ago and still when
people are running this is like by
themselves in their own machines are
kind of limited by the amount of
processing power you had if you think
about a good model a good model in place
that is probably gonna have to do quite
a lot of work and then on top of that
we've got a lot of data now if we match
those two things together we need a lot
of those things on the right to start
processing it these things on the right
here are on our TP use you don't have to
use TP user could use GPUs or anything
else but TPS are actually very useful
for us we bring out with brew out
second-generation this is worth standing
still cuz I think this is one that
differentiates us with Google cloud in
this in space and machine learning so
these things are 180 teraflops per
circuit they're a six or they're
designed specifically for a certain task
in this count in this case actually
calculating floating-point operations
182 what does that mean it means if we
put them in a pot and I'll show you a
photo that in a moment sorry Shelby and
she knows why so well she'll be said to
let you all in the joke when I showed
you this photo she said it looks like
something from the 1970s I'm a kind of
1970s guy well you know I like the 70s I
like a lot of stuff in the seventies so
this really appeals to me these are our
pots of actually of those TP use each
pot is 11 and 1/2 pet pet or flops what
do those numbers mean in real terms what
do they mean for anyone else they mean
we were translating so for example we
were taking our models like translate
and Retraining that in a couple of days
and now we can do it in a couple of
hours so if you think about these use
cases that maybe were involving lots of
data and lots of complexity now we have
the ability to actually go and retrain
them in relatively short amount of time
and to get a new model out there which
could potentially impact our
conversation with our users so the
message I want to take from this is that
machine learning is a really good fit
with cloud cloud officers you see this
this it will provide you this
infrastructure to go and actually take
advantage of that so how do we do that
well we do it in two ways so on the one
hand on the right hand side here we have
our managed api's this is a little bit
about and the democratization of the
machine learning so what we're trying to
do in the machine learning space is get
more people involved I just explained in
my last talk that I have two children
and whilst I'm not sure if my children
are gonna grow up and become data
scientists and I think one wants to be a
firefighter and the other one we're
gonna find out but I know when they grow
up and they participate in the world
machine learning is gonna be there it's
already here now we're on the cusp and
things are just accelerating I want my
kids to know what machine learning is
what it's about and more importantly
what people are using it for I don't
want it to be something that they don't
have that connection with the world that
the world just kind of passes them by in
our effort to democratize artificial
intelligence and machine learning what
we're trying to do is provide a space
for people to interact with on the right
hand side we're taking models that we've
actually trained to solve let's say
common problems
OCR taking a translation going from
speech to text we're open them up on
open API so that developers can use in
their applications making single rest
calls to actually get a result so you
saw the video demo earlier you know
those kind of things so that's one way
of kind of opening up a list of usage
and getting more people interacting with
the capabilities on the left-hand side
we have tensorflow and cloud machine
learning the big I would say the big
differentiator between Google cloud and
other clouds and I think that other
clouds are actually following us so
we've definitely have the lead in this
space and it was the reason why I joined
Google as well I'm a you know a big
data fan and if you look at the big data
technology a lot of it there's a
relationship with Google either they
publish white papers or in the most
recent years open sourcing a ton of
frameworks so why is this important
tensorflow is an open source project for
machine learning it has something like
50,000 stars on github so you saw Linux
has 20,000 imagine how many people are
involved with this then we know everyone
knows Linux people have an affiliation
with Linux
so 50,000 that's you know one and a half
times what they're actually they're
using I should say two and half times
but they're they're using it you know
experimenting with it so first of all
there's a lot of collaboration that
innovation that we spoke about earlier
about actually having people contribute
to this space and seeing what's going on
and moving that the needle is the same
thing what's happening machine learning
having an open source means we can all
collaborate and work together and we
have a managed service so and we do that
for our data a Big Data and frameworks
as well but we have a managed service
that you can take your model come and
run it us it kind of puts the kind of
let's say the responsibility square on
our shoulders to do a couple of things
make sure that we're giving you the best
price make sure that we're providing the
best security and make sure we're
providing the best performance and if
not you've written in an open source so
you can go and run it somewhere else so
you know your investments in good hands
also if a lot of people are working on
this project it means there are a lot of
developers and data scientists and
analysts out there in the market that
are working with it so when you're
looking to recruit more people to
actually accelerate your effort in that
space there are people in the market
that understand this technology you
don't have to go and just start from
scratch and train on something new so
open source is a really big part of
machine learning as well if you're not
using an open source framework for your
machine learning shame on you you really
should start considering it because it
really will put you in a better position
for the future
this is a quick architecture and we
don't have to go for all the details
here but what I basically say this is
the architecture of the video API the
most difficult part of this the part
that cost the most time to program was
the front end the stuff that you saw
and we do that in app engine that's my
my egg is now hard-boiled so we do that
in App Engine all the stuff on the
bottom is basically completely service
so you take your video you upload it to
cloud storage we have serverless
functions there listening and if there's
more events happening we will spin up
automatically more functions and then
with each video we pick up we will call
the API process it extract the metadata
we take the metadata so we're like with
the labels that you saw earlier which
lead Emin strated we see which indexes
it happens and we will serve that up in
this case we're putting it back on to
cloud storage we could put that in a
database or whatever else we want to put
it so we can make it searchable and
available for our application so you can
already take if you think if you've got
something around those API so it just
mentions like speech to text translation
processing videos processing images you
know extracting sentiment from if images
or recognizing where people are standing
on images are many things you can do and
you can just use a service architecture
and really get up to you know hit the
ground running if you're going to go
deeper and you're going to start
building some stuff yourself there are a
few things I want to leave you have to
actually think about in that process and
make sure the developers that are
working for you are giving you good
answers on these questions so we want to
do machine learning we want to be here
at the top doing our machine learning we
want to start gamers predictive power
making a business impact it is right at
the top of this stack right at the
bottom is infrastructure so again using
a framework like tensorflow that you can
run on basically any architecture that
gives you that capability if you're in
using another project which doesn't have
those capabilities and then you want to
take something and bring it into
production you're gonna have you have to
find you have your engineers find a way
to actually making that taken up from
the research base into the production
space that is one of the key motivators
behind tensorflow and inside Google
itself the Google brain team they were
working they were doing research stuff
and then when they try to move it to
production basically there had to be an
engineering effort to take that those
learnings in that model and now how are
we going to get this thing in production
so having infrastructure that we can do
that on and having the applications that
facilitate that it's a very powerful
thing as we move up we come to the kind
of let's say the body of water and the
data that we need to actually run this
on some of the key challenges there are
around collecting data processing data
these are all major efforts that need to
be made if you're actually going to use
machine learning so you have to have
good answers to these things and then on
the top we can do machine learning if
you don't do it like this you end up
like this and this is basically what
happened you'll be up there anybody like
oh that's saying of production and bomb
it's gone you know and you've got a big
problem this architecture and I won't go
into too many details about this at the
moment but I would just say that this is
an architecture we use to help customers
build things when they're using tents
flow and the important parts to kind of
look at here is that we have frameworks
like dataflow which is this one here
which is capable a unified batch and
process a streaming framework what that
means is I can take an action that I
want to perform our data like a mapping
or a function I want to form a sound
processing action and I can apply that
to batch data so think about the data
that you already have that you want to
use to train your model but I can also
apply it to real time data dates are
coming in on a stream the same model
just making a few changes of how the
dates actually coming in that's why a
unified model allows you to do so if you
look at the bottom there that we have
data for again so when you're ready to
make those predictions sometimes people
forget I've just spent all this time
taking this data extracting all the
features and then I trained a model now
we're going to go make predictions what
are you going to make predictions on
yeah I'm going to make a prediction on
this okay so what do we have to do with
that to actually get it in the same
space as our prediction yeah you have to
extract those features and now you see
why having a unified model might
actually make a lot of sense they're
both server lists as well and again as I
said they have open source projects
Apache bean which you can create your
stuff online have your developers create
your stuff on all the things I said
about tents for apply to Apache room as
well developers working in a community
you know there's something which you can
go and run on different infrastructure
if you want to move that flexibility the
other one is the cloud ml so here we're
using it to train our data and here we
are using it to predict a question that
comes up quite often if I create
something intense flow where am I going
to make my predictions well it's up to
you you could take your 10
hello model and deploy a compiled
version to your mobile phone so you
could for example you would be doing
translate and like I've seen the example
where we actually take a you take your
camera and your hold it up against the
sign for example in Japanese and then it
gives you the English text but let's say
you're not online at the moment you
still want that functionality to work so
you might be saying in your application
if I don't have an internet connection
use this local model which you know it's
going to be smaller it can be less
powerful if I do have a connection then
use this model you know and then you
would make an API call and then you can
come back to cloud machine learning so
you have that ability tensorflow itself
I'm letting you into like some of the
things I I explained to develop this as
well because I think this is where
things kind of go wrong if you're if you
if you're not asking these questions so
I just told you about all the good thing
about tense flow this is the engine a
tensorflow if you want to improve the
engine you'll have people work together
to actually collaborate in that space
but there's a lot going on there at the
moment it's pretty solid
as you go up the stack these are the
kind of important things to pay
attention to layers if you're building
models there it's a great place to learn
about machine learning but it's a place
that when you want to move from one
architecture to another you need to go
and think about how they're going to
look how's that processing going to go
run that's why we created estimators and
canned estimators an estimator itself
gives you the ability to actually just
say this is my model this is something
without doing all the wiring up and we
have a custom estimator as well so you
can take advantage of like something
very specific that you want to create
and you can take that model and then run
it on your local machine but then also
say to cloud them all for example go and
run this in a cloud and training on Big
Data - is really important the thing to
take home it's really important to kind
of challenge people what at what level
are they interacting with this stack
where are we where should we be and
right at the top there are the canned
estimators and these things are very
these are kind of out of the box they're
not like the machine learning API so
that I showed you you still have to
actually tell how your data is going to
fit and you have to extract the features
and do more of that kind of stuff but
basically if you've got like a common
problem like a common a regression
problem saying that there are estimators
there that you can use as well and
Charis Charis is another framework with
which you can use which we support as
well a lot of data scientists are using
carrots as well it also gives you
flexibility of backends so there are
things to think about there and there
are things that you know to have that
discussion with your lead data scientist
or the product manager of your data
science team that saying how are we
actually going to do this through a date
range into and just start asking some of
these questions it's not about
necessarily actually understanding
what's going on in all those layers but
it's having good answers like are you
gonna build them or like okay can we
train that in different spaces
what's the effort that you need to make
to help me get this to production
because I want this in production
because I want to actually start
offering new capabilities to my
customers this if you get any time left
today which I'm imagining you won't but
if you do have any time downstairs
there's an instant insights demo and
basically they show cloud ml making
predictions about which advert to show
her to show which taxi so imagine taxis
driving around town and some are coming
from the airport going into town and
other ones are going back some had three
people and some of two and it's this is
a running model you can go and look at
and basically see the whole flow so we
take the message and once we receive
that message we make a prediction and
say oh look there's one person in a taxi
they're heading to the airport maybe
they'd like to have a coffee or there
are three people going into town maybe
they'd like to go to this theater show
you know you can draw your own
conclusions what's a good idea but the
thing is this is all service so you can
actually go and see how you would self
this production pipelines and the other
thing is here as well to say is that we
can take data and the same data that's
coming in to make our predictions we can
filter off and have it going to our for
example bigquery which is our data
warehouse streaming real-time with the
data it's already there so when someone
finds up and says there's a problem you
can actually look at the data you've
been receiving and query not only the
data you had yesterday but the stuff
that's coming in now these kind of
capabilities enable you to act in this
space they enable you to make things
quickly they enable you to to get it to
production and they enable you to
actually start working with in
production when you have problems that's
the story that we have around machine
learning this is a photo of a TPU and
I've got six minutes if there are any
questions
I'm happy to take some silence
come on someone give me a question yeah
so I would say there's a few answers so
the question is yeah I'm gonna I'm going
to repeat it yeah I got that
so the question is like we're natural
language processing how do we cope with
different stacks which one should we use
is like is one open the other one closed
how do we kind of navigate that space so
the open API so that we have those api's
will give you capabilities out the box
and I think if you're bringing that so
if I was designing an application and I
wanted for example my application is
let's say a message let's say I'm taking
the reused example earlier with that
chat so the chats coming in and I want
to process the chat and actually have a
signal real-time about saying if the
person's happy or angry so I can after
the chats finished I can maybe steer
that chat somewhere else to actually had
someone call back or look into what was
going wrong you know and give a very
short turnaround if I was looking at
bring those capabilities to an
application let's say soon quickly I
would look at those api's and see if
that fits because I think you can really
speed up your development the good thing
there and if you're going in that space
is choose an API which is got you know
built on a good standard a good rest
standard and you can actually it's a
little work to implement and you can
actually let's say proxy so you can put
something in front of it and actually
work with it and if you want to change
that out for some other capability or
some other vendor later that the
engineering effort is very small if
you're going to go Frank let's say more
specific and you're really trying to
target like nuances which were very
unique to your use case use something
like tensorflow
as opposed to let's say one of our
competitors offerings which is a little
bit more closed because tensorflow is an
open project if you get into problems of
it's not about one company saying this
is our thing it's a it's something
supported by a whole group of people and
they will give you okay but they will
give you a help in that space they will
give you a chance to take the
development further and importantly a
question I got asked recently and I
think it's really worth thinking about
as well was at some point some
organizations are going to get asked a
question and that question is going to
be to an auditor explain me how it works
and that's going to be an exciting time
so if you get that question it's going
to be really
have a system that you're using which is
open and you can use tools to actually
look at what's going in at each level to
provide data to the auditor say look you
might not know if at least I can show
you what's going on this is happening
there it's not just some black box and
your core business is now tied in to
this thing that you can just say well I
ask it something and it gives me an
answer you know there's a big dialogue
around tense flow and even the models
that we use internally we have a lot of
efforts spent for example do like
inception model for images is a train
model and images we've brought out into
community so other people can develop
their own image that's there's a lot of
shared knowledge in the space so it
really tried to be in that space with a
shared knowledge so you can have access
to people but also get access to what's
going on when you need to does that
answer your question okay thank you if
other questions we have a mic now so so
everybody can hear the question this is
your chance this time for one last
question if there's a pressing question
for one last question yeah right if
one of the issues with speech
recognition and living in the
Netherlands is that Dutch is mostly one
of the last languages you support what
is the speed do you think that something
like that will come here so if you're
talking like actually special processing
speech-to-text
so I'm not going to commit to any like
planning on stage I do know from my own
personal engagements with country or
personal I say like within the business
context that we're really open to have
that conversation if is if it's
something is going to change what you do
and you've got a stake in it we're happy
to be a partner to explore the
possibilities so we're happy to add that
conversation we are obviously working to
have that support for all languages it's
just a question of you know engineering
resources and and linguists and
everything else that we need to make
that happen so a lot of our models have
moved into the NLP space at the moment
so you see a lot you know much better
but if you need if you have a specific
requirement around that maybe reach out
to the the sales field cells it's on
your table if you have someone there
otherwise I points on your direction and
let's have that that conversation
there's something we're really happy to
talk about Thank You Ellie Robert and
Robert will stick around so
so in a sort of natural way that agenda
changed a little bit and at this point
we will be at our round tables and your
table lead will lead to discussion and
we take it from there okay
my name is Mario and I'm gonna be your
host for the next 45 minutes because I
loved the interaction you're currently
having on a roundtable and we're gonna
go a little bit deeper we're gonna make
from the conversation we're gonna turn
it into a challenge so I hope you're
excited yeah a little bit okay so why
are we doing this we are going to apply
a little bit of design thinking this is
something that's very deeply embedded in
Google and we want to share with you how
that works but before I gonna explain
what we're actually gonna do I want to
recap a little bit and give you some
context so digital is radically
redefining how consumers interact and
our businesses are being shaped or
knitted Richmond need to transform if
you think about the early 2000 it was
through the web now it's through this
device and in the very near future it's
going to be in much more ambient ways if
you think of all the intelligent devices
that are around you and can provide and
can help you in any context so for
example Gartner forecasts that in just
two years time one-fifth of the world
population will have a virtual personal
assistant that I will use in their
mobile device and at Google we see the
same sort of transformation going on
more than 50% of all the queries happen
on this device but what really strikes
me is that 20% of these queries are
voiced based and that leads me to the
following thought this is a new area of
consumer experience
it creates a new standard so think of it
as you're not only competing against
other companies but you're actually
competing against the best experience a
consumer has ever had regardless of
industry so at Google we have the
mission to organize world's information
make it relevant and universally
accessible and we do that in many ways
and in shapes so what we're going to do
next is to give you a closer look how we
are using that in the Google home in the
on your mobile device and even in the
car and more importantly how you as a
business can also benefit from that
so with that I'd like to introduce my
colleague Lee give her a big round of
applause and after that I'll come back
to you to explain a little bit more
about the challenge
[Music]
[Applause]
so hi everyone my name is Lee von Stroh
I work as a customer engineer for Google
for Google cloud tea and I'm here today
to talk a little bit about Google home
and Google assistance just how that
works out on the road also chatbots
this picture that you see here is
actually a picture it was made in 2016 I
was on a Google i/o this is our CEO
cinder and he came on stage and he said
like at this time from now on we will
move from a mobile first world to a more
AI first world now what does he mean
back in the past when we were creating
applications we made it that way that
will make sure that it works on a mobile
phone because if it works on a mobile
phone and then we can just resize it
with responsive design and so that it
runs across any type of device for a
very long time that was our way of
thinking our design thinking how you
would create applications but now we are
at a time that we collected so much data
and we have so much computing power in
the cloud that we finally can change our
way of thinking and make a more AI first
approach where we let our applications
or interfaces be created by machine
learning and we do that with the Google
assistants the Google assistant and that
is our smart assistant it's implemented
in all the latest Google products that
you can buy like think about the Google
watch think about Android phone I think
all Android phones from marshmallow
lineup the Google home the smart speaker
but also in cars we're trying to
implement it there so that you can when
you're driving in a car you can ask like
oh how is my commute to Paris
how should I Drive he turn on the radio
and instead of looking through a screen
are interacting with the screen so it's
a conversation between you and Google
that helps you to get more things done
in this world
now just to make a couple of things
clear the Google home that is the
voice-activated speaker and it's it's it
really is nothing more than a speaker
that's connected to the Internet and as
a microphone you can talk to it but but
the whole magic around it that is
actually the Google assistants so that
is the conversation between Google and
you and that's implemented in the phones
but also in the Google home
now you will also hear me a couple of
times referring to actions on Google now
what is that think about it as apps it's
how you can extend the assistant so you
can create your own conversations your
own chat logics and implement that on
top of the Google assistant and we can
do that with tools like API the day.i
which I will talk about later but just
to let you know what Google systems can
do you can ask the Google system to
manage tasks this this folder that you
see here is actually a question to the
assistant like yeah what's my
confirmation number to my flight to
Philadelphia and then the Google
assistant will answer you with the PNR
that they get from the from the slide
how does that sister know that well
you're locked into a Google account
which is connection to your email and
all then you calendar and so on so the
Google assistant is smart enough to
figure that out for you you can ask
things like okay how will how will my
transit be hot like Esther is busy on
the road and the Google systems will
know that by connecting to all kinds of
external services so you can use it to
plan the day you can also use it to ask
questions so I could for example as like
who is the king of the Netherlands and
the assistant will answer well that's
Willem Alex on there but then my next
question could be like okay and what's
the name of his wife and then even the
assistant will know that the context is
willem-alexander so his wife
her name is maxima so I mean that is
that is something that is very smart you
need more than I mean then then a
decision chair to figure that out you
need to understand the context you need
to understand what was passed in and to
keep that context you can use also the
system for making memories so I can ask
like oh what is my favorite my favorite
color is blue and if I ask the Cougar
assistant next week what's my favorite
color again then the system will know
well you told me it was blue so he can
remember things and you can also use it
to control your home if you have all
types of smart devices like the Philips
hue box or the nest like I said I got
turn on the lights turn up the heat turn
the volume on or play my favorite TV
show or me on youtube or on Netflix as
long as you have smart devices that are
connected to the Internet and your your
Google assistant can communicate with
that
[Music]
here I came up with an example how you
can implement that logic for Google home
or for the Google assistance within your
company I mean we're working on at
companies and I assume that we all have
internal applications running they those
are applications that run behind a
firewall so one of such application
could be a meeting room application to
book to book a meeting room so I could
for example ask the existent like hey
okay Google
let me talk to book a meeting room book
a meeting room in this case it's my
custom action that is to action that I
as a developer will create and what you
will see is the Google assistant will
talk back and they'll say like ok sure
here's bucha meeting room and then at
that moment the voice of the assistant
will change because then it will go to a
voice that the developer chose for their
custom action so you're coming into the
custom action flow now so like think
about it as an app or a flow and we'll
start asking with the welcome intent
like okay welcome how can I help you and
I say like ok yeah like to book a
meeting room for three persons sure for
when tomorrow from 2 to 3 p.m. and what
happens here is tomorrow from 2 to 3
p.m. or I want to book a meeting room
for 3 persons three persons is a
parameter that will be sent to an
external system so it imagine that you
have a book a meeting room internal
application which has a REST API I just
pass in three persons and then the API
would handle it back I would say ok the
next the next request that I should make
is a request by the time ok tomorrow
from 2 to 3 p.m. and then the system
will tell me back like ok it went fine
and meeting room is booked and then the
systems can tell me that or the meeting
room was not booked because maybe it was
already booked before and then it can
come up with respect in the suggestion
something thing like this it's not so
difficult to to create with it - like
API that AI API that the AI is it's like
a developer console it's like a SAS
application a website you go there and
you can create all these intents so you
can write out these conversations but it
also contains machine learning so you
can train the system so when you ask
questions it becomes smarter over time
if you ask the question a little bit
wrong it will understand which question
you meant because it got trained through
a machine learning so API today I that
is the developer console that you can
start using and when you use that you
create your conversation only once and
then you can implement it for various
solutions so I can deploy it on Google
home I can deploy it on Facebook as a
box and then I need to add that person
as a bot as a friend in my Facebook
account and I can start talking to it I
can have a chat bot on my website I can
implement it easily with an iframe or I
can integrate it real in my in my own
system and in my own look and feel for
phones you name it we have all the
integrations there already available in
the API today I a developer console it's
just a matter of flipping a switch
actions SDK that is a client library and
that's currently written in node that is
in case API today I is limited for you
or in case you want to extend and do
some more magic then you can choose to
implement all these ideas by yourself
it's a little bit more work because then
you also need to come up with a natural
language processing a machine learning
which API today I has out-of-the-box
so here you can see it again that can
you book a meeting room for tomorrow
from 2:00 to 3:00 p.m. I call webservers
book a meeting room and I pass in
tomorrow 2:00 to 3:00 p.m.
[Music]
their intent this is API today I you
create a weapon tender and that you can
see that as a kind of flow it's a
mapping between what the user says and
the action that needs to be taken so for
example I created a while ago on a
Google home application where I could
ask go home like hey what's on TV
tonight I want what you know I want to
know what's on TV on RTL 4 and then it
would read up it would read out the
whole programming guide how would I do
that
I would create a weapon tent where I ask
what's on a channel and then the user
can pass in whatever channel they like
but it will ask take that whatever the
this part it will be fired to the
backend and yeah and I assume that I
have some some kind of magic or some
kind of service there that can query the
TV Guide the thing that I passed in that
is an entity so you can predefined a
bunch of entities see it as parameters
so you know that there is some kind of
hard variable that you need to send to
the system so there you can act on
[Music]
yeah this is what you see here here you
create the weapon tents there the
entities there's a session for
integration since for changing if you
want to deploy it on Facebook or on
slack or on skype there's also a section
for training the API so or if you have
created these weapons and that people
have been asking questions yeah you can
train it you can correct it if they gave
you the wrong answer you can say ok well
next time don't answer this anymore and
then it will remember that here you see
the web book and parameters so you can
create web hooks this is actually you
just you enable a web hook and then you
pass in the URL to your external web
applications and then when you create
your intense you just click on actions
and you say like ok every time when I
ask this event or this intent actually
you need to act on it fear through a web
hook and then I give it a web name in
this case kept a channel that will be
passed to that URL
now what I did in the in the background
for this is I use cloud functions but
you can use any type of back-end you
like the reason why I choose Google
cloud functions is because in this case
I don't need to worry about the virtual
machine or a server I just create a
function somewhere in the cloud and then
let Google's kill all the machines for
me and I just don't care about backends
at all so I just create a JavaScript
function in this case that would query
the TV guys we don't I don't think we
need to go into this now this is very
technical but ask me if you have
questions about it just so you know
these kind of cloud functions you can
write that on the Google cloud in an in
a native editor on the cloud platform so
you don't need to install any tools you
can just do it right away yes
and then you deploy your action and once
you deploy your action then you can test
it so this is within the Google cloud
platform there is a web simulator and
then you can you can authorize it with
your Google accounts and then you say
like this is my API today I account that
I'm currently using and at that moment
you kept in the simulator you get like a
similar behavior as if you would have a
real Google home so I could start typing
to it and it gives me answers back but I
could also use the microphone for my
computer and ask questions and then it
would read out the answers as if it
would be the Google system
and once you're done when you're really
happy with this with this conversation
and then you can yeah deploy it kind of
like an app store you need to register
the name and then will be white listed
in the in the google app store or an
assistant app store kinda that means
that there's a proof of process somebody
within Google will check your your bot
see if it's valid enough
see also if you're neglecting microphone
open non-stop because that is actually
one of the guidelines you can never
leave the microphone open out of the out
of the box that doesn't work on a Google
home it always keeps it open for a
minute or maybe less and then
automatically shuts off but if you don't
let your users know that the microphone
is open then your refill your refill
process will fail so make sure that you
always ask for more questions so when
you create a con conversation you should
always answer like okay this is the
answer do you like to hear more okay and
this is the answer
and in case you're really interested in
this and creating google assistant
conversations or using api today i there
is this design document that google
created that can help you with creating
conversations like this definitely a
good read I think with that I can hand
it over to you Mario Thank You Lee what
we try to do is to basically show you
the technical toolkit so the next
ingredient we want to share with you and
after that you're really gonna get your
hands dirty
is a conceptual creative toolkit so if
you can switch to the next slide thank
you yeah so this is all about creating
the future you now have the opportunity
together to create a future together
if you go to the next slide so at Google
we think of creativity in innovation not
as an event we see it as a process
perhaps even more as a mindset and we
worked a couple of years ago together
with Stanford's idea and a couple of
other experts to develop this method
which is called design thinking and
basically it consists of three main
concepts so I wanted to walk you through
because I think it's very useful in your
exercise so the first one is if you are
starting to build something you don't
start with a revenue model and buying
some great technology it always starts
with knowing the user
once you know the user their beliefs
their needs that's the perfect starting
point to build a magical solution now
the next part you want to do and
basically again some practical guides
you could you could apply a framework of
three pillars of knowing the user the
first is analyze so what data do you
have available to analyze the user
second one is observe their ways you can
observe your users and the third one is
to ask them there's no better input than
asking a user how they feel what they
need etc so the second one andre kuipers
already touched upon we don't think in
incremental improvements of 10% now we
want to improve and think about 10x a
perfect Google example I think is Google
loon in rural areas where there was no
Wi-Fi it was a childish idea to come up
with air balloons that could send out
Wi-Fi signals but it's these ideas that
in a grown-up setting are considered
impossible which are the strongest ideas
so ask yourself in the team what if
because asking the what-if question will
make it bigger and the final one is be
product driven you want to make sure
that you fail fast because if you
incorporate that you will you will learn
if you succeed but also if you fail and
you can incorporate that learning so we
see the success not by how high your
success rate is but how often you have
tried something
huh
okay go to the next one
all right so coming back Lee gave you
the technical toolkit how you can build
a conversational customer experience I
hope I've just gave you a little bit of
a toolkit how you can have a creative
process to come up so we're going to put
that together so the challenge we asked
you and you can continue the
conversation reading your roundtable
redesign the customer experience by
creating a concept that uses this
conversational AI so that's your
objective we're gonna have handout
tables on the round tables which is a
framework you can use to put in your
ideas you're gonna be time limited I'm
sorry we already far over time but again
you only have 20 minutes your chance to
win a Google home I'm afraid I I can't
keep up with that promise we don't have
Google homes unfortunate but the
important thing is there was not
intended to be in there so apology it's
gonna be Netherlands end of year we're
gonna score based on business impacts so
how big is he impacts you're gonna come
up with a concept
what's the customer experience like so
who is your customer what are the
integrations you could use so that could
be your own data could be external data
and finally originality
could you make a flow describing the
conversation you would be having with a
customer with one of your partners and
please etc
okay go to the next time so as a final
example to give you some food for
thought this is a very cool concept that
I bade them out a couple of weeks ago so
I bought a camera six years ago but with
the technological advancement of
smartphones I think the camera in my
pocket is far more powerful and easy to
use so I don't use my big camera anymore
so what I actually could ask eBay is how
much is my camera worth and it would ask
me a couple of questions like okay tell
me the brands the color the condition
and it would then search in its own
great database and could provide me with
a very precise estimation of how much my
camera is worth I think these are the
kinds of concepts you might be thinking
about
so with that I wish you all good luck
and a twenty minutes starts now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the end of the challenge so please
finish your discussions it's a good sign
I think you're having great
conversations so at the end of the
challenge what we'd like to do is to
have a couple of teams come on stage to
share with us their great concepts take
them up so are there any volunteers that
think my concept is the next big thing
awesome
what's your name sir Edwin hi Irene can
I ask you to pitch your concept you and
your team came up I will alright so the
idea started from the company I work for
who a part of the activity is a retail
store around gardening pets and baking
and what we wanted to do is to create
Rob the personal gardening coach because
what we are we are a retail store or
retail chain that provides premium
products with a premium and advice and
by doing so justify a premium price but
of course if we have to wait until the
customer shows up in our store with a
problem that we can help to solve and we
might miss an opportunity so the idea
would be that we create a personal
gardening coach which is a chatbot in an
app so that when a client of ours walks
through the garden and spots a bug on
some of the plants that he can open the
app call up Rob and say hi I've got a
problem I've spotted a bug and then the
chat bot would say ok let's see what we
can do can you send me a picture which
would mean access to the the camera you
send a picture and then you start an
entire conversation and at the end of
the conversation
you would have a solution to the problem
you would have the link to a product and
we'd be able to tie it to an online
order or a reference to the nearest
store to come and pick up the product
that we might be provide to them and
then it became really Spacey because we
said you know we have added value
services what would you think if we'd
send over a drone right now to do a scan
of your garden as an ad your valid
service so that we can find out how your
garden is organized and whether this
book we spot it might spread out to
other areas in your garden yeah that was
one of the fancy ideas around it so
what is the business impact well the
business impact is that we are there for
our clients the moment they spot
something so the moment they detect
something that we can assist them and
find the solution we can tie it back to
a full full experience with an online
order or a reference to a nearest store
and we would get better in size because
if we spot a buck in a certain area and
we know that that is something that
spreads very easily we would be able
based upon client information to send
out warnings to other clients saying
well there is something going on in the
neighborhood be aware and if something
goes wrong with the plants there's a
very light or beacon likelihood that it
might be linked to this in terms of
integrations well voice API image and
video API geolocation where are you dear
mr. client but based upon what you have
on the phone that's easy then of course
the client profile data we have
geolocation weather data API maybe there
is something wrong in that area because
of lack of weather or lack of water or
something lack of rain like we are
experiencing right now and then of
course yeah a bug disease and solution
database that we need to tie it all
together so you see a lot of integration
points and we're not even talking about
the drone so on the customer flow that's
what I already explained so the customer
journey you walk through the garden you
see something and you open the chat bot
and you start having a conversation I
loved today one one question which you
also have a female assistant of course
great I love the idea
any other volunteers coming front
now what's your name sure yeah it's
excellent
yes thank you well my name is Heath's
and we're in the homecare business I
think you're supporting the home care
system in the Netherlands it would be
shortened Atlas so we looked at another
solution for homecare nurses so the
nurse assistant would be a male I think
so probably I think they're really
independent nurses they're most assigned
at home with patients so assistant would
be appropriate I think most of the time
there needs to well to supply themselves
with materials for wounds for other
things for the patient at home so there
are things they will need external
people to to help them that's one thing
we do with our company to just help them
with IT solutions to pretend information
but I think the customer experience
could be giving to supplying them with
medical supplies without any extra time
for calling two other companies for
delivering them so the the business
impact would be they will have much more
time with the patients that's something
we always want to try to do with our
solutions so so that's let me brief
something well that's most important
business impact I think that would that
will have most more time with the
patients and less time administrating
things so the assistant will start I
think with personal healthcare records
social media ratings could be an
integration for looking up ratings for
suppliers speech API of course
electronic health records we already
have and maybe personal data from
patients when they are at home when you
want something to delivers well how good
at work so the assistant would ask what
what do you need well it's I know it's
mr. X because I'm already there so the
system knows he has a wound okay well
what do you want to do based on the
wound
well I want some new supplies so it
could be a question you can ask through
this to the assistants well in
connection with the data that we already
have or could be available that you
could say well if they're already I
won't order materials ordered can we ask
you when you're at home at what time
should it be delivered so it could be in
combination typed outs based on some
questions and eventually they will
supply order the supplies and I think
the benefit would be that the supplier
would do the rest so the nurse can do go
to the next patient so that's part of
our a brainstorm session solution thank
you here so no more visits to the doctor
we have room for one final concept yeah
one more you want to go as well okay
we're gonna have two ladies first
but you need to be a little bit shorter
on time to make sure that we cover both
thanks what's your name's Divya
good afternoon everyone my name is Divya
and the products or the innovation that
we are launching is called as companion
so it's a companion for the elderly
people and we see that there are lots of
issues in our society now because all of
us are becoming very individualistic
there's lots of growth in the elderly
age group and they have lots of aging
effects going into depression feeling
loneliness and lots of old age illness
so what is the business impact through
our companion would be that we will
increase the quality of life for the
elderly
we will bring happiness to their life
and we will improve their healthy life
State which in turn would help us in
society and lower the health cost and
the insurance cost and I will go to the
Cosmo flow first and then the
integration so it's a morning the Google
home talks hello Richard so the
interaction is starting
from the Google home so it's not like I
have to speak to my Google home it's
Google all speaking to me and through
natural language processing and LPS
vivvy we can identify the mood of the
person we can identify time of the day
we can identify the agenda of the person
looking at the weather health of the
person we can have a call to action in
terms of each one of that to give you an
example if I haven't spoken since
morning it will call to action to my
friends or family that there is
something wrong I'm not in a right mood
or I'm not having good health so it will
call my relatives if the weather is nice
it will call my friends to play a bridge
with me if it's raining outside and if I
have to go outside it will advise me to
carry my umbrella so this is the
customer flow just to give you an
example and the integrations third box
was integrations to api's it could be
with voice recognition to interpret my
mood
it could be with the healthcare systems
the weather data the sentiment analysis
insurance companies medical records and
the pillbox thank you
really amazing the last team that can
present with a plant oh my god
is this your Google home what's your
name sir hello Peter
hi one minute okay you want to be sure
you ask me to be short huh
okay
actually this is Wilson you know Wilson
from the movie outcast actually the
first the lady ladies first
her ideas brilliant actually we had the
same idea but we already have the
solution here this is the interface for
the elderly you can speak to your plant
it sees you it feels you so this is the
solution and we just build on the api's
that they are making so you know here's
the partnership and actually the first
team how to make sure the plant doesn't
die right okay cool
excellent so I'd like to close off I
hope you've had fun a great interaction
with your table learned some new people
some new ideas and I really hope that
you can take away to start tomorrow
building the new future using some of
the conversational toolkit so with that
I'd like to close off please give
another round of applause for yourself
[Applause]
and I'd like to invite Erika dot for the
closing session
it's okay hi everyone so I understand
I'm the left the last speaker so I try
to be very sure so I want just to give
you to not let you leave without having
the saisiyat update state of the
business that we have hopefully now with
Google Cloud so I'm running the business
for Google cloud in Europe so I'm
looking at container type countries in
Europe so anchoring benefits of Holland
and Belgium and with samba and with
already with the leadership of Holloway
and that you know and so you know why I
joined Google on top I actually wasn't
on top ice six years ago and I used to
often hear that Microsoft before so I am
in this cloud business for vini
discarded for the last ten years okay
what I can see and what I can say is at
the beginning finally the description
was coming from from Google to Microsoft
actually okay with real-time platform
and maybe mobility okay what was the
kind of discussion we could see at the
beginning so what was very beginning so
we saw kind of linear who also K on the
cloud adoption
depending on the country but we could
say that Nordic countries where maybe a
little bit early adopter courses where
you can you guys well and always we
start to see quite a big acceleration
this is shift description comes from
machine learning and data management is
where I see a description and this way I
see when I discuss with customers like
you
from all industries across job what we
see is a lot of discussion related to
machine learning that imagine why
because that there is a big impact with
a business Francis there was a big big
driver auditor to business and CEO CEO
and Sunday they look for this kind of
impact and I think they can look at a
very direct correlation so we see this
acceleration and what what we do as well
in order to dry this acceleration to
invest so we are we have probably
learned about that we have aprox 500 new
releases of services we've been having
that for the last 12 months and we will
continue so we have quite an ambitious
world map we are missing 28 billion
dollars of capex in terms of data
centers and infrastructure over the next
few years so the big big big investment
from Google in us in order to build web
hasn't very serious in this Google it is
cloud business and and we are looking
for more investment so we want to be a
real partner for enterprise not only for
start-up for starters startup and the
dot-com companies I think were quite
organized about that we want to invest
more in order to be sure that front wise
business or industries we have we we
have this disco conditioning as a
partner so we are when we see in your
success and I mean that we are not
selling product free I mean this is the
kind of mindset that I want to team up
with you this mod we are trying to to
understand your challenges your
priorities and in order to make that we
are here guys or team in terms of the
articles industry so we are trying to
have people with a mindset of a vertical
like banking like manufacturing like
gaming and so I'm going to be sure that
we understand for sure from day 0 we
cannot assign everything but at least
people in the team we try to learn from
your challenge and
gravity's not we have to be sure they
understand and they can give you good an
swells
okay so in order also to be sure that
you benefit from best practices we also
trying also to Internet to share best
practices that we have in terms of
economy still ought to give you some
solution in terms of error in terms of
what works or what doesn't work in terms
of business erosion and lastly in terms
of support something very tangible we
are as we speak behind 3000 people
technical people for Chris from PCs to
posters it's quite big I can tell you
since I just googled first time I see so
big you having investment so I'm part of
the committee of hiring so every week we
have a dozen of a new County days that
we approve and hopefully we we are able
to bring these people in front of you
okay for workshop but also for post sell
technical support and any any ship or
technical advice that you need today we
have some lists we can happen it is her
diet so I should have remove it
actually I'm sure I'm sure you use use
of these dis lights or you know in a few
also we have two too young to me on
customers on top ice customers okay
b2b to customers and what's new today
quite with some modesty okay we're
working with all industries I will say
that before so I mean this is some
vertical we're a little bit risk adverse
with we saw you know with the cloud and
maybe with Google and so today we work
with big bomb like deviations we see as
an G so we we have a whole conversation
and your partnerships on partnership
with with Bank we
to strong partnership with a fumarole
not as well so and as you know there is
a quite very important rule called
gdpr in Europe to come by by May next
year so we are in the we are planning
order to be absolutely compound for that
we need to be absolutely absolutely
comfort with that will be compliant okay
so it's I can tell you this not because
I got some question related to that gave
relax this is all life is okay if we are
not GDP are Bryant we we stop the
business okay
we beat GDP are compared so we have a
plan for that will you communicate maybe
we don't communicate enough okay and we
just come to more in order to say we can
better communicate actively with with
our orchestra not to be shot you
understand the plan and roadmap and for
sure I need to mention that we have
quite a huge business with with later
and a fashion and so in all Europe most
of the big ground not all that many of
the people in retail and fashion and
related business we have quite a good
partnership there is no good customer
discussion without a good with a
partners and I would say the partnering
evolution has been somewhere mirroring
of of the business ok so when the
business was wasted unnatural okay like
nish the partners were mostly niche
partners okay very good partners but
initiative tells and the more we
evaluate and we all free we get we get
to a level maturity of this business and
the cloud business and the level of
conversation is natural for you
and the more we also other partners so
we diversify partners we have also still
niche partners very specialized but we
will show more and more large large
global si like Exxon true or equivalent
and also software-as-a-service kind of
application providers now also
completing the ecosystem of partnership
so and to be very clear partnership for
us is quite important this strategy we
have we cannot die comment section with
you but we are we have always partners
not between us but at these Wizards in
order to be sure that we have the best
compensation for you and that the
adoption and the success of project is
is guaranteed talking about patterns I'm
not going to talk too much in details
but I wanted to take the opportunity of
this session to give you an example of
three or four customers okay well from
the first one is visited deformed
different scents face that we did in a
satellite satellite imagery okay so the
problem was to deliver a high quality of
image when you have snow okay you can
imagine that in an image when you have
snow you also also cloud as when I said
Club not Idid cloud I'm in the cloud
where car the sky and so it's quite it's
quite difficult to identify with what is
cloud and what is now okay and and so
what we did was hire them to serve a
poem that was Spanish they spend several
years to add to in photo quality and in
few months a couple of months I think
three most maximum we will free improve
a lot to quality of the image so that
means customer satisfaction that's
quality to machine learning customer
satisfaction
and three more business Hokkaido that
pure grocery online the UK quite a good
one in the UK many today so they have
new store you probably heard that some
companies like Amazon but stores okay
and so this company does not have store
they are only online so two four four
for them the key success factor is
customer services they need to have a
fantastic customer satisfaction and be
sure the answer to any program very
actively so in order to manage and to do
a triage of text to messages of course
from the customers okay they're using
the platform machinery perform in order
to interfere and not Frieda can swear
when there is a time companying their
cannons were very quick years and so the
issue the business as well
Spotify you know probably these leading
companies in music streaming so the
value proposal and and the prom they
they want to be sure that every one of
us I the opportunity to have all the
music you want we want in your hands so
what we do is to to make possible to
have a maximum for combination
suggestion to a two to two users in
order to be sure they they are happy
with the music off with a get from from
from Spotify you get the last example
allocated is quite a very old company
with all the oldest one company very
traditional in fourth part of the CAC 40
the century company and they they were
in the process of acquisition and growth
as well so looking for new talent and we
are not able to acquire so much because
the idea was quite upset and not
organized to acquire new companies so
what they did was to start the process
of perfection with BC the Boston
consider group and from this firstly
they went to the question of a night
where they call an AI lab
laughs okay out of the company to
understand and to look at the new
processes and new ideas of business and
usage they need to have for entering the
new world of digital they did it and
from that we enter in the digital
transformation we have them to manage
transformation of all their users
I mean fifty thousand users and now they
just got the acquisition of a gas in the
u.s. twenty thousand users and we are
working with them for the next next
transformation that the kind of
transformation we did so all commit not
to to to you so and that somewhere what
we need to others as a DNA when you we
are in occupies is it's fair to be sure
that you have access to when you are
customer prospect or partner we have
access to all the innovation innovation
from Google by discussing with product
manager but with discussing with all our
people based in Amsterdam or in Europe
and also to our partners or ecosystems
so we are also looking always new
partnership in order to bring more value
to you or in terms of in terms of
benefits for your user or for your
customers looking at always and that
principle I love is having since I work
for traditional companies I would say I
love to see that we are not looking not
looking can't actually technically
commercially the the business with you
so what what we are trying to do is to
always be very open in terms of platform
in terms of conceptualization and be
sure that when you awfully you work with
us and we have a partnership this
partnership is not something like one
unique a mano partnership it has to be a
lightweight partnership we understand
perfectly well that you should do that
and maybe is that an advice for me you
should be more you should have a multi
cloud strategy in order to be sure that
you can of free managed benefits of all
von doors and leverage what you need
okay
and so lastly
so something quite new because when I
look at my the first years I was working
at Google I was worried that we didn't
have efficient services so the beginning
so we are having some support no free we
have a proper home services organization
that not a professional services
relation that is for replacing the
partners is for completing the partners
or just to be sure that you are you feel
secure okay or free you you feel that
your project we go to success okay and
that just for that okay the purpose of
this professional services that we want
to be big enough to be good not good
great in terms of impact for you but not
to be to not create some uncover of for
the particle system is part of the plan
out of three of the new Google cloud
that you want to have for you
so my conclusion I think that the first
time I in advance it's 120 only one
thing I would love that you keep is if
you are in the process of introduction
with Google Cloud today one thing you
should just open for conversation for
discovery workshop okay work with the
team I'm sure you know most most of the
people in the in the ancillary office or
the the boss's office start position for
discovery workshop and in notify the
project where we could help you okay
maybe problem that you don't know how to
solve maybe we have a solution and we
can we can that free locate a totally
free you can you can spend some invest
some time with you you not to be sure
that we can get some some panel for year
of really work okay so no need for big
project we start we can start small
description look at what you need short
term after we learn by working together
so that that I'm feeling I'm done with
with my presentation I told you short 20
seconds
left and it's not that we have oXXO
cocktail
andre probably because on that so we
have a couple of some glass of wine or
three good wine help
boom I'm not sure yeah good wine so I'm
happy to fill up with you okay
discussion happy to discuss with you
[Applause]
thank you Eric and thank you everybody
and I hope the wine is good and this
brings to the end of this day and I
really hope you enjoyed and got inspired
today with the keynotes with machine
learning with all the possibilities that
we brought I really hope that you got
inspired by imagining the future like
you did I hope you got inspired by
exploring possibilities with the design
thinking and all the things that went
that we discussed I saw some great
examples of that and I don't want to
close really actually instead I want to
do two proposal swoops I want to do two
proposals one stay connected so all the
folks here on the tables right so we
have customer engineers with Lee and we
have here the business people with pedra
every table has them we have a services
organization we have a partner
organization we have a marketing
organization and by the way super thank
you for Suzanne and Shelby for pulling
this off
[Applause]
I want to propose stay connected and
start a project in a safe environment
because we believe at Google to just
create a safe environment and an
experiment stuff to start stuff just to
maybe some stuff that's already bubbled
up at the tables here let's continue
let's continue the discussion now we all
connect it and let's let's keep the
conversation going in a safe environment
and it's okay to fail don't worry and do
it a few times you know how that works
right and at some point the future you
imagined might be closer okay the second
proposal is and Eric already gave a
little bit of heads up we have a boat
right and the boat is park we you can
get on the boat from five o'clock so if
you walk easy to the boat and there will
be lollipop girls and boys and it'll
bring us to the to the boats and we have
an awesome time to seven o'clock on the
boat with nice drinks and I hope the
wine is good really Eric I hope so so
thank you again